là monsieur bonsoir voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce vendredi 10 août
accident d'avion en polynésie entre
moorea et tahiti il ya 16 morts et
quatre disparus l'appareil s'est abîmé
en mer peu après son décollage
ce type de bimoteurs effectue des
liaisons régulières jusqu'à 40 par jour
entre les deux îles de l'archipel
l'hommage du pays au cardinal jean marie
lustiger ce matin à paris une cérémonie
qui a commencé sur le parvis la
cathédrale par la lecture du kaddish la
prière juive des morts et s'est
poursuivie ensuite dans la basilique où
3000 personnes avaient pris place pour
le président de la république crise
boursière sur toutes les places
internationales la banque centrale
européenne de même que la fédérale
banque américaine injecte des liquidités
pour éviter le krach que tout le monde
redoute envoi de trois jours qui
viennent et si le temps le faire mais ce
sera le moment idéal pour observer le
ciel ils peuvent relayer toile fine
entre 340 sites sont ouverts au public
pour ses dix septième nuit les étoiles
et puis nous retournerons à marciac dans
le gers où le festival de jazz a changé
la vie de toute une petite ville de
nouvelles classes au collège et havrais
développement économique
c'était un bimoteur en bon étant avec à
ses commandes un pilote chevronné qui
s'est abîmé en mer au décollage entre
moorea et tahiti
sur les vingt passagers il ya peu de
chances de retrouver des survivants pour
l'instant seize corps ont été repêchés
les victimes sont essentiellement des
polynésiens qui utilisent régulièrement
ses avions la liaison la plus rapide
entre les îles de l'archipel sept
minutes à peine le secrétaire d'état à
l'outre-mer christian estrosi doit se
rendre sur place
or nos bernard
vingt personnes se trouvaient à bord de
l'appareil près de 24 heures après
l'accident quatre passagers sont
toujours portées disparues même s'ils
continuent leurs recherches
les secours n'ont quasiment aucun espoir
de retrouver des survivants au moment du
crash l'avion a été pulvérisée on était
sur place en ont mis une trentaine de
secondes peut-être et on a constaté
simplement tout tout un tas d blé aux
surfaces et avait avait des corps quand
même le vol vers tahiti devait durer
sept minutes
l'avion s'est abîmé en mer 30 secondes à
peine après son décollage de mort et à
le bimoteur effectuer la navette entre
la petite île et la capitale tahitienne
le twin otter construit en 1979 avait
été acheté il ya un an par air moorea il
avait subi une révision le 18 juillet le
commandant de bord était un pilote
expérimenté fort de 3500 heures de vol
l'accident reste pour le moment
inexpliqué
il n'a lancé aucun sos fait de rentrer
et le thé courage
j'ai vu l'avion monte à 500 pieds et
d'un coup il est là la piquer parmi les
victimes on compte des polynésiens deux
touristes australiens et deux
fonctionnaires européens en mission dans
l'archipel à papeete les familles des
victimes ont été prises en charge par
une cellule d'aidé psychologique sur
mort et à une chapelle ardente a été
dressée dans un gymnase
au son des chants polynésiens les
habitants de l'île sont venus rendre un
dernier hommage aux victimes du crash
des experts du bureau d'enquêtés et
d'analysés de l'aviation civile sont
attendus demain matin à tahiti
l'avion n'est pas équipés de boîtes
noires ils vont tenter d'établir les
causes de l'accident
une cérémonie très émouvante à l'image
de la personnalité de jean-marie
lustiger où la prière juive des morts le
kaddish a été lu devant le cercueil sur
le parvis de notre dame de paris avant
la cérémonie religieuse
le corps de jean marie lustiger a
ensuite été inhumé dans la crypte de la
cathédrale
laetitia legendre et mickaël garreau de
la terre prélevés en terre sainte au
mont des oliviers
l'arrière petit cousin du cardinal
lustiger la dépose sur le cercueil
le feu le kaddish la prière juive pour
les morts sur le parvis de notre dame de
paris
l'hommage de toute une communauté venus
saluer la mémoire d'aaron jean marie
lustiger juif converti au catholicisme à
l'âge de 14 ans le fait que le cardinal
et désiré qu'il y ait une cérémonie
juive
ses obsèques et très très significative
de la relation qu'il avait avec le
monde juif le peuple juif 500 prêtres 70
avec des représentants orthodoxes
musulmans juifs que fédère une
personnalité atypique aux côtés de la
famille
le président sarkozy des personnalités
comme lech walesa ou bernadette chirac
des membres du gouvernement et les
immortels de l'académie française dont
il fut membre dès 1995
l'image d'un homme au dessus des hommes
vous fûtes le cardinal juifs il est venu
à l'académie le dire je vais je ne
reviendrai plus je vais partir on se
reverra plus tard je dirais que ça des
membres de l'académie qui étaient
présents ce jour là il aura fait un
cadeau extraordinaire parce qu'ils
auraient leur a rappelé qu'ils étaient
l'essentiel de la coupe c'est que seuls
sur cette terre qui nous mourrons qui
font garder la main la république et
l'église
réunis pour un ultime hommage j'ai voulu
honorer la mémoire d'un
d'un grand homme d'un homme qui a compté
pour les français
qu'ils soient croyants ou non c'était un
homme de paix de rassemblement de
réconciliation
le cardinal jean marie lustiger reposera
dans une crypte aux côtés de ses
prédécesseurs
sa dernière demeure sous le choeur de la
cathédrale notre dame sa paroisse
pendant près d'un quart de siècle
premier le personnes avaient pris place
à l'intérieur de l'église 2000 autres
s'étaient massés sur le parvis de la
cathédrale
tous ont voulu saluer la mémoire d'un
grand homme bruno timsit et foncera
pitrel une prière sur le parvis de notre
dame
un dernier hommage au cardinal lustiger
l'homme a marqué à jamais ceux qui l'ont
rencontré
c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup compté
dans ma vie voilà que jc de sur parra
pour ces prières tout ce que ces gestes
là que j'ai le souvenir de quelqu'un de
de très attentif très très doux
en percutant dans la
la foi chrétienne dans l'émotion les
fidèles parisien salue la mémoire du
cardinal et veulent suivre le chemin
qu'il a tracé
c'est quelqu'un d'une foi qui
qui tient interrogeait qui
impressionnait lui 2
suivre la même route de marcher dans ses
pas deux mille fidèles n'ont pas pu
rentrer ils suivent la cérémonie sur
écrans géants
tous se souviennent de l'action de
monseigneur lustiger
ça a été quand même un homme qui a
utilisé justement les médias qui a créé
et qui a fait connaître qui s'est
occupée des pauvres qui c'est au gré des
malades et qui a démystifié un petit peu
casse cou et un petit peu le carcan de
l'église dans la foule des personnes de
confession juive venue rendre hommage à
cet homme né juif est devenu cardinal il
est devenu chrétien mais l'aja n'est
jamais renoncé
aso qualité de juif et je trouve ça
admirable quelques heures sur le parvis
de notre-dame beaucoup garderont l'image
d'un homme de dialogue
soucieux de réconciliation faut-il
laisser en liberté même sous contrôle
judiciaire un homme il en examen pour
pédophilie c est une question qui oppose
magistrats et policier âgé de 50 ans un
homme a été arrêté dimanche son parc de
disney alors qu'il filmait une petite
fille dans des positions équivoques chez
lui les enquêteurs ont découvert des
images pédophiles et il a reconnu avoir
déjà eu des comportements déviants
explications anouk burel et emmanuel
maurel la scène se passe dimanche
dernier à disneyland dans les rues du
parc caméra au poing un cinquantenaire
film une petite fille en train de
baisser sa culotte
en réalité l'homme est un pédophile
présumé il a jeté du poil à gratter sur
la fillette pour la filmer interpellé
l'homme est mise en examen dans son
ordinateur les enquêteurs retrouvent des
photos d'enfants et des vidéos perverse
il reconnaît les faits notamment des
attouchements très poussées sur l'une de
ses nièces en 2000 vidéos amateurs à
l'appui aux yeux de la loi c'est un viol
décision du juge d'instruction l'homme
est placé sous contrôle judiciaire
strict il ressort libre colère d'un
syndicat policier
on le vit très mal on tente policiers de
travailler toujours plus pour pour
empêcher ce genre d'individu de nuire
mais on ne se place pas en jugement sans
peur simplement la détention provisoire
pour nous est un élément essentiel sur
des faits aussi graves
réponse de l'union syndicale des
magistrats la détention provisoire n'est
pas la règle
au contraire la loi rappelle qu'elle
doit rester une exception
d'autant plus depuis l' affaire outreau
et la loi clément c'est pas parce qu'on
est en présence d'une infraction de
nature sexuelle quand elle même ça
justifie le placement en détention
provisoire si le magistrat n'a pas placé
fait personnes en détention provisoire
c'est parce qu'il estimait que les
critères légaux n'étaient pas réunies
pour le placer un d'entre eux en
détention provisoire
je rappelle que cette personne est
soumise à un contrôle judiciaire très
strict
l'homme a notamment l'obligation de se
faire soigner en attendant son procès le
juge d'instruction estime qu'il présente
des garanties suffisantes
experts ont conclu à la non dangerosité
mais le parquet a fait appel de cette
décision
en ariège à ax-les-thermes deux enfants
ont trouvé la mort dans l'incendié de
l'appartement de leurs parents on ignore
les causes exactes du feu mais des
banquiers estiment qu'il pourrait
provenir de la poubelle de la cuisine
incendie s'est déclaré vers 20 heures
dans un immeuble ancien situé dans le
vieux centre ville d'ax les parents qui
étaient absents lorsque le feu s'est
déclaré ont tenté sans succès de sauver
leur enfant le petit garçon de 12 ans
qui est tombé du 4e étage de son
immeuble à amiens hier est toujours dans
un état très grave à l'hôpital
il tentait de suivre son père qui vous
déchire un contrôle de police en
s'échappant par les balcons la famille
en situation irrégulière a demandé sans
succès l'asile politique
lionel faure stein et carole et
libbrecht ils reviennent à peine de
l'hôpital où ils ont passé une grande
partie de la nuit aux côtés de leur fils
ivan l'enfant de 12 ans est toujours
dans le coma
jean paul ii de mon fils et j'espère que
les saintes et les bas ça c'est pour moi
le premier
c'est pas moi seul que rennes hier matin
l'enfant a fait une chute de quatre
étages en tentant d'échapper à la police
en compagnie de son père
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
suscite aujourd'hui la colère et
l'indignation des associations des deux
sans papiers elles ont organisé cette
marche pour dénoncer ce qu'elle appelle
le harcèlement policier
c'est la face émergée d'un iceberg que
des familles qui sont traqués y en a
partout en france en ce moment comme
l'année dernière nous avons marqué qu'au
moment où tout le monde part en vacances
en particulier des enseignants
les travailleurs sociaux la traque
s'accélérer le couple en situation
irrégulière a été convoqué cette semaine
dans ce commissariat après quatre
demandes d'asile rejetée
il était menacé d'expulsion pourtant la
mère d'yvan a toujours affirmé se sentir
menacé dans son pays la tchétchénie où
elle vivait avec son mari d'origine
chrétienne c'est une famille mixte qui
est rejetée là bas pour cette mixité
c'est un cas qui auraient dû être
traités dans le cas dans le cadre de la
circulaire sarkozy ne l'est pas et ne
l'a pas été pour une simple raison de
quotas selon le procureur d'amiens les
policiers ont respecté toutes les
procédures
une enquête interne a été demandé ce
soir
ivan est toujours hospitalisé pour les
médecins le pronostic vital est réservé
panique fébrilité inquiétudes crise mais
pas encore de krach boursier les banques
centrales font tous vous rassurer les
marchés la banque européenne et la
banque américaine injecte des liquidités
pour maintenir les cours et tous les
spécialistes incite les petits porteurs
à ne pas perdre leur sang froid et ne
pas vendre leurs portefeuilles
même s'il depuis le début de l'année à
paris par exemple tous les gains ont été
annulées avec un recul total de 1,6 pour
cent
julien du père et eric de l'agneau je ne
vendrai pas négatif nous vendrions aux
très mauvaises circonstances 1500 appels
par jour du jamais vu dans cette société
de gestion de portefeuilles boursiers au
bout
fil des petits actionnaires de plus en
plus inquiets face à la chute des
marchés les clients fait veulent savoir
deux choses d'une part il veut savoir ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle sur les
marchés le veulent bien évidemment
savoir si cette correction est
temporaire
face à ger habituels ou si cela va durer
à ces questions les analystes financiers
répondent par un conseil il faut laisser
passer la tempête
car tant qu'il n'a pas vendu ses actions
le petit porteur ne perd pas d'argent il
ya vraiment aucune raison de vendre ses
actions aujourd'hui il faut les
conserver attendre que cette phase 2 de
crise de confiance passe crise de
confiance venue des états unis où
l'immobilier va mal
en fait les ménages américains les plus
modestes ne peuvent plus rembourser
leurs crédits immobiliers
du coup certaines banques sont dans le
rouge et wall street chute - 2,83 hier à
new york une baisse contagieuse tokyo
hong kong francfort paris et londres ce
soir sur toutes les places c'est la
dégringolade
conséquence plus personne ne veut
prendre le risque de prêter de l'argent
ce sont donc les autorités monétaires
qui une à une met la main à la poche en
deux jours 156 milliards d'euros pour la
banque centrale européenne
c'est deux fois plus qu'au lendemain des
attentats du 11 septembre
cet après midi wall street a ouvert une
nouvelle fois à la baisse fin de semaine
très agitée les investisseurs ont
jusqu'à lundi matin pour reprendre leur
souffle pour certains c'est déjà la fin
des vacances pour d'autres c'est le
départ pendant tout le week-end et
jusqu'au 15 août la circulation sera
chargé sur les routes de france où le
voyez samedi sera rouge dans le sens des
départs comme des retours dimanche
en revanche la circulation devrait être
plus fluide les jours de grands départs
sont particulièrement préparée dans les
aéroports à roissy près de 200 mille
voyageurs ont transité tous les jours un
afflux qui nécessite une organisation
particulière visite dans les coulisses
de ce site de 3300 hectares avec marion
pilates et damien louvet
les jours de départ en vacances béatrice
mais toi ne lâche pas son portable elle
est importante ou pas cette responsable
des aérogares traque les ascenseurs en
panne et les bouchons au guichet depuis
son poste de contrôle aucun recoin de
l'aérogare ne lui échappe à roissy elle
est le chef d'orchestre des départs en
vacances
aujourd'hui on est vendredi jour devait
pas mois d'août personne va rater son
avion tout le monde rêve étant raté son
avion je ne sais pas mais il n'entre pas
responsables on fait en sorte que tout
le monde arrive en temps et en heure en
salle d'embarquement
voilà ça c'est notre mission chaque
minute à roissy un avion atterrit ou
d'école le long des pistes
les 21 pompiers de l'aéroport doivent
être prêts à intervenir à la moindre
fumée suspecte
des incidents mineurs qui pourrait
générer toujours souhaité attendre l'été
voire les conséquences catastrophiques
c'est l'impression combien alerte sur
les pistes par jour lui à deux verres
par jour mais aucun incident majeur
cette année à peine côté rogard quelques
malaises de voyageurs un remède contre
le stress de l'embarquement
les 3000 mètres carrés de boutiques où
certains prennent largement leur temps
partager pendant cinq minutes de vol
sera terminé et il s'en va là ne sont
pas là c'est un week-end chargé qui
commence pour voici près de deux cent
mille voyageurs se présenteront à
l'embarquement entre aujourd'hui et
dimanche
sauf bien sûr imprévu de dernière minute
dans l'est de la france de nouvelles
crues cet après-midi ont touché à
nouveau le doubs notamment besançon
après l'alsace et le haut-rhin et hier
de nombreuses routes sont coupées et les
pluies continues et lisa kudrow la
rivière s'est invité jusqu'au coeur du
village
conséquence des fortes pluies de ces
derniers jours ledoux a débordé sortir
les bottes et les cuissardes
les habitants de ce village au sud de
besançon en ont l'habitude
mais en été c'est du jamais vu l'hiver
on a toujours toujours au moins une fois
une petite crue des fois des grosses n'y
a pas de problème mais là au mois d'août
jamais à besançon le pic de la crue a
été atteint vers 17 heures six mètres 33
dans tout le département les pompiers
ont multiplié les interventions ici
c'est une plate forme de chantier qui a
dû être sécurisé la barge de 25 tonnes
menaçait d'être entraîné par les eaux en
alsace le rhin aussi ceux des chaînes à
gottesheim vers midi le débit était
quatre fois supérieur à la normale
les autorités ont donc décidé de mettre
en å le polder d'erstein un espace
inondables de 600 hectares une mesure
pour contenir la crue une première pour
l'instant le polder est plein aucun
incident signalé
l'édiction sous surveillance par nos
équipes tout se passe bien ce soir un
peu partout la décrue est amorcée
les fortes pluies sont terminées et le
grand nettoyage a commencé et pour ceux
qui sont déjà en vacances il faut
souvent faire contre mauvaise fortune
bon coeur la pluie et le froid ont tombé
j'ai beaucoup à faire preuve
d'imagination
notamment ceux qui sont partis en
montagne certains ont adapté leur
activité d'autres ont choisi tout
simplement de rentrer à la maison
reportage virginie fichés et philippe
lévêque des châteaux de sable au pathé
debout les petits s'adapte à tous des
matelas qui flottent des tentes qui
décomptent
les plus grands eux se lasse et courtes
souvent leur séjour contient deux jours
trois jours mais au bout de trois jours
de pluie et de froid
c'est plus possible cointe d'autres sans
test étant de se constituer un cocon
douillet échaudés ou refroidi par de
précédentes expériences cela en ont tout
prévu cette année prévu un petit
chauffage pour essayer de nous
réchauffer et surtout enlever l'humidité
heureusement pour les vacanciers la
beauté des paysages n'est pas la seule
richesse des monts du forez ce vieux
moulin à papier par exemple s'accommode
très bien du mauvais temps contrairement
à certains étaient les pluies
entretiennent le bief qui alimente sa
roue et conduisent les touristes à
l'abri de ces effets murs de pierre en
juillet on a eu un peu plus de monde que
l'année dernière environ 500 personnes
de plus sur le mois qui a dû compter à
peu près sept ou huit mille visiteurs on
aurait quand même aimé ne pas avoir la
pluie pour voir un petit peu marché pour
pouvoir découvrir les paysages noyé dans
une brume presque irlandaise
on croise parfois au détour d'un chemin
des vététistes obstiné sillonnant contre
plus des nuages la campagne auvergnate
se faisait toujours beau à cette adresse
en charge les gens viennent pour le
plaisir de rouler de faire un beau
circuit est bon au moins ce plaisir là
le plaisir sportif sera pas trop gâché
et comme souvent la chaleur qu'il n'ya
pas dehors
on la trouve dans les assiettes autour
d'une bonne fondue à la fourme déjà un
peu d'hiver au bout de la cuillère la
mort d'un adolescent de 16 ans qui a été
retrouvé dans des hautes-alpes il était
pensionnaire d'un centre de vacances et
il avait disparu au cours de la nuit de
son centre à villar d'arène on ignore
dans quelles circonstances il s'est
retrouvé seul à cet endroit au milieu de
la nuit
cette mort pose évidemment la question
de la surveillance des jeunes dans ces
centres stéphane despinoy et benoît
jourdain
l'adolescent a été retrouvé au pied
d'une barre rocheuse à l'endroit même où
il s'entraînait à l' escalade hier avec
son groupe
c'est un randonneur qui a découvert tôt
ce matin le corps sans vie du jeune
homme à 800 mètres seulement du camp
nous les jeunes passait la nuit il avait
disparu peu après minuit et les
gendarmes ont vite été prévenue la
gendarmerie a effectué des recherches de
1h30 jusqu'à 4h30 du matin mon regard
des conditions météorologiques très
difficiles puisqu'il faisait 2 degrés en
plus on a vu une nuit sans lune donc des
difficultés encore une fois pour pouvoir
observer que s'est il passé entre minuit
et 7h ce matin toute la journée les
enquêteurs ont recueilli les témoignages
des douze jeunes pour savoir si leur
version concorder des adolescents choqué
bien entendu une cellule psychologique a
d'ailleurs été mise en place ici à
villar d'arène a priori d'accidents et
la thèse la plus probable mais le
parquet de gap n'exclut rien pour
l'instant c'est le mystère qui
subsistent nous ne savons pas ce qui a
pu se passer entre le moment où sa
disparition nous est signalée et le
moment où on découvre son corps sans
ambition ce soir le parquet attend les
résultats de l autopsie qu'elle a
demandée fugue accident ou autre
hypothèse les moniteurs de callas en
tout cas n'ont pas voulu s'exprimer
les adolescents viennent de quitter le
camping municipal ils rejoignent leur
centre de vacances basée aux deux alpes
en grande bretagne 4e troupeau est
suspecté de ses oeuvres aphteuse ce jour
dans le sort est le problème c'est que
cette ferme se trouve en dehors de la
zone de protection ce qui signifierait
c'est la contamination était avéré que
les dispositions confie d'actifs n'ont
pas été efficaces
par ailleurs les tests effectués sur le
troisième élevage a battu montrent
qu'ils n'étaient en fait pas contaminées
par la maladie de son père et dominique
marault tél depuis la nuit dernière une
quatrième ferme a été placé dans le sud
de l'angleterre sous contrôle
un périmètre de sécurité a été instauré
les autorités ont décidé de procéder à
des tests pour vérifier la présence
éventuelle du virus de la fièvre
aphteuse nous avons décidé de placer
cette ferme quelques doutes sur la
présence du virus
ce matin le fermier de cette
exploitation a confié à quelques
journalistes qu'il était quasiment sûr
que son bétail n'était pas touché il
attend bien évidemment avec impatience
le résultat des examens
depuis le début de la crise les
autorités ont établi différentes zones
de protection autour des fermes touchées
cette quatrième ferme suspectés se
trouve à dorking à l'extérieur de ces
zones et cela soulève beaucoup
d'inquiétudes depuis début de la crise
le gouvernement fait tout pour limiter
l'extension du virus dès qu'une ferme
est touché elle est isolée par une zone
de protection et le bétail est abattu
aujourd'hui on a appris que la troisième
ferme suspecté n'était en fait pas
infecté 362 animaux de cette
exploitation avait été abattu par
précaution en fait ils n'étaient pas
valables
cet après midi le premier ministre a
tenu à rassurer l'opinion publique les
gens en grande bretagne à l'étranger
doivent avoir confiance
le tourisme dans nos zones rurales ne
doit pas souffrir de cette situation
ce soir tout le monde attend les
résultats des tests effectués dans la 4e
ferme pour le moment la grande bretagne
donc toujours deux foyers de fièvre
aphteuse et le virus jusqu'à preuve du
contraire est toujours limité à une zone
très précises nouvelles déclarations du
fils kadhafi à propos des infirmières
bulgares pour la première fois il
reconnaît qu elles ont été torturées et
menacé au cours des huit années de leur
emprisonnement en libye le fils du
général kadhafi avait déjà admis qu'elle
n'était pas responsable de la
contamination des enfants par le sida
philippe rochoux
c'était hier sur la chaîne arabe
al-jazira le fils kadhafi reconnaissait
que les infirmières bulgares ont été
torturés il y a bien eu des tortures à
l'électricité et aussi des menaces de
s'en prendre à leurs fans
cet homme qui a servi d'intermédiaire
dans la négociation n'a pas toujours
tenu ce discours dans une interview au
journal le monde trois jours après la
libération des infirmières
il affirmait le récit de torture sont
exagérées c'est de la fiction à 100%
entre occident et monde arabe le
discours libyen est donc différent mais
les fêtes sont là dès le 24 juillet à
leur arrivée à sofia les infirmières
bulgares et le médecin palestinien
on parlait de menaces de viol de
morsures de chiens et de tortures à
l'électricité
la douleur était insupportable je
pensais que mon coeur allait s'arrêter
que je ne reconnaîtraient pas je pensais
vraiment que j'allais mourir
les libyens reconnaissent donc la
torture c'est un argument que les cinq
infirmières bien décidée à porter
plainte contre tripoli
ils vont pouvoir utiliser le texte où
elle s'engage à ne pas attaquer la libye
signé sous la contrainte n'a aucune
valeur juridique
le médecin palestinien lui veut
carrément porté l affaire devant la
justice internationale
à rome c'est une partie de la mémoire du
cinéma italien qui a disparu hier dans
l'incendié de plusieurs milliers de
mètres carrés des studios cinecitta cet
immense complexe de 40 hectares à
abriter les tournage de plusieurs films
d'anthologie
frédéric retard et karine guillaume la
scène n'était pas prévu dans le scénario
la nuit dernière c'est une partie d'un
décor de téléfilm historique qui a
disparu en fumée
un court circuit dans un entrepôt est
probablement à l'origine de l'incendié
à certains endroits les flammes ont
atteint plusieurs mètres de haut
on est venu voir ce qui se passait et on
a vu des flammes très hautes nous sommes
très inquiets espérons que ce ne soit
pas trop grave
pour nous tu n'es tu ta c'est un
patrimoine historique important ça fait
mal de voir ça les pompiers italiens ont
mis deux heures pour venir à bout du
sinistre
ce qui a brûlé ce sont ces décors
construits pour les besoins de la série
télévisée anglo-américaine rome car
aujourd'hui cinecitta travail presque
exclusivement pour la télévision et la
publicité
c'est mussolini dans les années 30 qui
inaugure ce qui allait devenir la città
del cinema la ville du septième art
on y tourne d'abord des productions
fascistes puis dans les années 50 des
films de guerre et puis c'est ici qu'en
suite de nombreux péplum faux concocté
le territoire de 40 hectares sera
surtout le repère des plus grands
cinéastes italiens visconti rossellini
et bien sûr fellini qui dirigera entre
autres la dolce vita est vite ennemi un
temps boudé par l'industrie du cinéma
cinecitta retrouvé il ya dix ans une
santé financière des gros contrats sont
signés comme gangs of new york de martin
scorsese 70 ans d'existence
un millier de films à son actif
cinecitta connaît là un nouveau coup dur
mais l' usine à rêves situé à 9 km de la
capitale italienne pourra continuer son
activité production
la navette américaine endeavour avec à
son bord sept astronautes dont deux
femmes deux et s'arrimer à la station
spatiale internationale vous voyez pour
une mission de onze jours voici
l'arrimage cette mission a lieu plus de
vingt ans après l'explosion de
challenger ou une autre institutrice
barbara morgan a pris part à ce vol en
france les vendanges ont commencé dans
l'hérault avec la récolte du muscat une
vendange meucon plus précoce que les
autres années dans beaucoup de régions
grâce à un printemps très ensoleillé
avec un vin qui s'annonce de qualité
mais en moins grande quantité les halls
envers ton et de johann lopez
jamais georges grise elle n'avait
vendanger aussitôt ce viticulteur
produit du muscat de mireval
depuis hier il a commencé la récolte de
muscat sec avec dix jours d'avancé par
rapport à une année ordinaire
ça va être parce que c'est fun il ya une
bonne saison le stadium prêtait et on a
des réserves du sort maléfique
coincé entre collines et étant le
vignoble de mireval dans l'hérault est
donc l'un des premiers à commencer les
vendanges
la raison un printemps précoce et on
était bien ensoleillé même très bon
nombre et les responsables de la cave
coopérative ont donné le signal du
départ il ya deux jours c'est en goûtant
le raisin qu'ils ont senti qu'il ne
fallait plus attendre en goûter les
graines et les arômes soldats donc on
peut vendre nargis et cette année c'est
vraiment une année très précoce oui
surtout pour le type de vin que nous
voulons faire car nous voulons vraiment
de faire exploser les arômes et donc là
on renie en plein en fait à mireval
les vendanges sont de plus en plus
précoces et pas seulement à cause du
climat jusqu'à présent ici on ne
produisaient qu'un vin doux naturel et
puis on s'est aperçu qu'en les
récoltants plutôt certains raisin
pouvait donner un très bon muscat sec
le muscat sec on s'aperçut quand même
qui ce sont des vins très aromatique qui
sont très demandés et notamment c'est
pour élargir notre champ d'action au
niveau commercial en france dont
beaucoup de régions les vendanges vont
avoir deux à trois semaines d' avance
mais les pluies de mai juin ont animé
beaucoup de raisin et la récolte devrait
être l'une des plus faibles depuis l'an
2000 pour regarder les étoiles mieux
vaut se trouvait dans le noir l'excès de
lumière empêche de distinguer des
étoiles filantes
il faut habituer l'oeil à l'obscurité
pour que tel les chats nos pupilles se
dilatent la pollution lumineuse
sellal ni majeur des amateurs des toiles
reportage au coeur de la campagne le
triangle noir du quartier dans le lot
avec romain messi et les manuels morel
loin des villes au coeur de ce parc
naturel ils guettent les premières
heures de la nuit
les astronomes chasseurs des toiles ont
traversé la france pour dresser leurs
télescopes et trouver ce qu'ils ont en
chercher le triangle noir du quercy
l'obscurité
l'absence de pollution lumineuse une
porte ouverte sur l'univers que
malheureusement on trouve pas ailleurs
paris la ville lumière et ses milliers
de lampadaires qui éclairent le ciel
autant que le sol un gigantesque halo
lumineux qui masque les étoiles on
appelle cela la pollution lumineuse sur
cette carte les lumières de la terre vue
de l'espace
les pays développés comme la france
brille de mille feux les endroits pour
observer les étoiles ils sont de plus en
plus rares le triangle noir du quercy
est l'un d'entre eux ici lumière blanche
interdite tête levée les amoureux du
ciel découvre la voie lactée et les
confins de l'univers
c'est sur un très beau
l'immensité le fait qu'on sent tout
petit
c'est une chose de magique une véritable
nuit noire comme l'appellent les
astronomes
un spectacle rare menacé par un
éclairage grandissant si on continue sur
le rythme on va en 2020 on devrait avoir
un ciel sur l'ensemble du territoire
français qui sera apparenté la belgique
où l'éclairage artificiel rend
aujourd'hui les étoiles quasi invisible
en france les astronomes se bat pour
conserver des réserves de ciel étoilé
comme le quercy pour que la nuit soit
toujours un spectacle
alors pour bien observer des étoiles
filantes il faut évidemment un ciel
dégagé un coin de prairies pour
s'allonger un clair de lune pas trop
présent explications et conseils pour
hausser 17e nuit les étoiles avec
evelyne goldman et camille facile à
regarder les étoiles les galaxies
manipuler un énorme télé scott ce n'est
pas si compliqué c'est même un jeu
d'enfant alors n'ayez pas peur d'essayer
ce soir des animateurs dans toute la
france sont là pour vous tenir la menthe
et regardez le numéro qui institue les
minimes 1 là c'est les premiers pas en
fait parce qu'on n'a pas eu un très beau
temps cette semaine mais n'en fait rien
de compliqué c'est juste une démarche
pas vous trouvez vous compliqué vous
barbe alors et si le temps le permet ils
vous montreront le ciel comme vous ne
l'avez jamais vu et vous donneront
toutes les explications vraiment
intéressant de regarder des objets du
ciel profond donc au typiquement basse
et la galaxie quinquis
c'est un ensemble de mignard des toiles
de nébuleuse de choses comme ça pas
parce qu'il ya dans notre galaxie anosy
et des nébuleuses
donc là c'est super parce qu'il peut y
avoir des couleurs douces que sur liszt
et des amas d'étoilés sésame à l'étoile
c'est tout un tas des toiles qui sont
très très resserré les unes à côté des
autres
ce soir 3000 professionnels ou amateurs
se met à votre disposition comme ici à
la base de loisirs de l'utiliser bros
pour régler vos télescopes mais aussi
pour vous parler de leur rêve découvrir
une autre terre on cherche évidemment
une planète dont l'atmosphère serait
semblable à la nôtre pour qu'on puisse
éventuellement un jour envisager d'y
déménager au moment où je vous parle on
doit en découvrir entre 2 et 5 par mois
donc ça va assez vite pour rencontrer
ces passionnés un site internet afa
net.fr plus de 368 où ils vous
transmettrons gratuitement leur amour
des étoiles rugby le quinze de france
rencontrera demain l'angleterre en match
de préparation du mondial 2007 à
twickenham au tour du capitaine raphaël
ibanez au poste de talonneur
à noter le retour de fabien pelous au
poste de deuxième ligne il fêtera sa
111e sélection égalant ainsi le record
de philippe sella
la charnière sera composée de pierre
mignon demi de mêlée et david skréla
demi d'ouverture frédéric michalak ne
sera donc que remplaçant et puis en
formule 1 à nouveau coureur français va
se produire l'an prochain il s'agit de
sébastien boudais il a été recruté par
une équipe pas très connus toro rosso la
france avait plus de pilote français en
f1 depuis olivier panis en 2004 joakim
noah le fils du chanteur et ancien
tennisman yannick vient d'être
officiellement naturalisés français mais
sur le territoire américain
il avait la double nationalité américano
suédoise naturalisation doré lui
permettre de jouer un jour peut-être en
équipe de france il ya 30 ans dans le
gers une poignée d'amateurs de jazz
optimiste forcené autour de directeur du
lycée et maire de la commune jean-louis
guilhaumon
fondée dans une petite ville entre
vignes et maïs un festival où il
espérait bien attirer la fine fleur du
jazz mondial
considéré à l'époque comme de doux
rêveurs ils ont transformé le quotidien
les habitants de marciac qui aujourd'hui
vivent pensent et apprennent le jazz
laurence cuvillier et bruno vignais
ahmad jamal 77 ans
le virtuose est l'un des derniers
rescapés de la génération build up des
années 50
jazz in marciac déroule le tapis rouge
aux plus grands
quels sont à votre avis comment je me
sens ici plutôt bien il ya trente ans le
festival c'était ça des bandes de
copains jouant dans la rue et un ou deux
grands musiciens pour parrainer
l'opération
depuis le petit village du gers a vu
passer des légendes vivantes les digues
il esquive sonny rollins ricciardo
michel petrucciani pas étonnant alors de
voir les enfants du village sur scène à
13 ans au collège d'une classe de jazz a
été créé le principe même de jazz
émoussé de partager la musique de
discuter par l'intermédiaire d'heure
d'instruments et justement éveiller les
enfants à se partager jusqu'au décès
très très bien jules et maylis ont
choisi la trompette
ils sont venus voir répéter wynton
marsalis qui parraine la classe de jazz
debout je suis tout petit j'aime bien
être en bête mais mais pas avant je
pouvais pas parce que avec mes dents fin
je veux pas encore je n'étais pas frais
d'inscription
depuis 15 ans le trompettiste de la
nouvelle orléans vient chaque été donné
des conseils aux élèves et jouer pour
les festivaliers
oui quand je suis venu la première fois
ce n'était pas le même chapiteau sont
pas pareils
c'était pas aussi grand que maintenant
mais c'était déjà pas mal
six mille personnes sous le chapiteau ce
soir c'est 4 fois la population du
village
wynton marsalis joue un morceau qu'il
est tout spécialement composée l'as
marciac suis désormais le festival a sa
partition
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
tous de l'avoir au suivi tout de suite
la météo avec isabelle martinez on suit
très important le point route avec
julien pascal 20h50 patrick sébastien
pour les meilleurs moments de son plus
grand cabaret du monde demain à 13
heures vous avez rendez vous avec
olivier galzi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain soir à 20h très bonne
soirée sur france 2 hadmar fois
bon